so I can potentially give you an
opportunity to talk a little bit about
the default mode Network can you talk
some about that and just you know the
potential value and dissolving the ego
yeah thanks for bringing that up the
neuroscience that I learned about was to
me intellectually the most exciting part
of doing this book and and and that
really is where we're learning what
we're learning about consciousness and
the mind so when when neuroscientists
first began imaging the brains of people
on psilocybin or LSD they would actually
like inject someone with the medicine
and slide them into that fMRI tube and
if you've ever been in an fMRI and
you've ever tripped imagine combining
those two things these volunteers you
know yeah deserve a hand that's designed
to be in this study that is serious
volunteer duty what they expected to see
though was and this work was first done
in Imperial College London by a
brilliant neuroscientist named Robin
Carhartt Harris who I profiled another
white male sorry to report but there it
is and and so they expected to see lots
of activity on the fMRI and you know
consistent with the fireworks that
people report but what they saw instead
was a reduction in activity in this one
particular network that happens to be
very important to our sense of self and
that is the default mode Network and
this is a set of structures in the
midline of the brain that connects
structures that are within the cortex
the evolutionarily most recent part of
the brain that has our executive
function and higher-order functions with
deeper older structures involved with
memory and emotion and it's a hub in the
brain lots of signals passed through it
it's like a Grand Central Station or
something and then it's also a regulator
as Robin calls it it's the conductor of
the nur
symphonie its and and so what does it do
well it's involved in self-reflection as
far as we know and self-criticism and
rumination it's where your mind goes
when it's wandering or worrying it's
involved in time travel the ability to
think about the future or the past which
is very important to a sense of identity
without a sense of time you don't have a
sense of identity it's involved in a
theory of mind which is the ability to
imagine mental states and other people
which is critical to moral reasoning and
ethical reasoning and it's involved in
something called the experiential self
this is kind of where we generate the
stories that connect what happens to us
at any given time to this the story of
who we are
so how interesting that when this
network goes quiet or appears to on an
fMRI that's when people report an
experience of complete ego dissolution
what good is that well the researchers
you know are still speculating about it
they do think that ego dissolution which
some refer to as the mystical experience
I actually think they're pretty much the
same thing one is a spiritual vocabulary
one is a psychodynamic vocabulary but
similar things happen when you lose a
sense of ego you you merged with other
things because the balls come down and
that permits a reconnection with other
people with nature with your past self
and that when our defenses are down we
can break out of the stories in which we
trap ourselves you know those really
destructive stories we tell about
ourselves and and depress people in
particular and addicts in particular the
story that says you can't get through
the day without a drink the story that
says that you you're unworthy of love we
get stuck in these loops of rumination
and recrimination and the psychedelic
experience of ego dissolution gives you
a new perspective it's temporary but you
see that wow you don't have to think
that way and those stories they're
they're broken they're there
their power over you is broken even if
just for some a period of time
but having had a taste of that other
form of consciousness where you're not
the victim of your loops of destructive
thought can be liberating so that's
that's a that's a theoretical hypothesis
of how it works but it's a compelling
one yeah and I think it's really
interesting this idea of decentralizing
the brain and it's very timely
considering this theme a lot people here
probably from the blockchain world you
know this theme of decentralization and
so in many ways psychedelics are like
the you know these centralizing the
brains they might add block chains or
decentralize and that since they're anti
hierarchical the experience and and
actually those of you have the book in
your lap look at page 318 sorry not
everybody has it but go outside and look
at page 318 later and there's a map of
the brain on a placebo and and on
psilocybin and there and so there's a
perimeter in this map and every circle
represents a different brain network
that the brain is organized in these
networks one deals with you know local
motion one deals with the visual cortex
and there are a few big highways in the
first illustration and when the default
mode network goes down all these new
connections form that have never existed
before the brain is temporarily rewire
and suddenly you have this explosion of
new pathways and we don't know what's
happening on those pathways they could
explain synesthesia right the phenomenon
of tasting in color that maybe the cross
wiring of two two brain networks or the
new insights or metaphors that people
report those may be a new way to connect
dots that's the exciting work to figure
out what's going on in that new map and
what kind of thinking happens but the
fact is the brain is being wired in a
new way temporarily and that temporary
rewiring can have last
the facts